en pleno himalaya nepal es uno de los
países más aislados remotos y pobres del
mundo tradicionalmente este país ha sido
una especie de protectorado de país
satélite de la india sin embargo amigos
a finales de 2017 el partido comunista
de nepal obtuvo una victoria aplastante
en las elecciones y ahora ha puesto sus
ojos en pekín en este vídeo te contamos
que está ocurriendo y también cuál es el
gran tesoro oculto de este país vamos
allá
[Música]
[Aplausos]
amigos os hago una pregunta y no vale
buscarla en google sabéis en qué país
nació buda 123 exacto en nepal un país
situado en pleno himalaya y que es el
hogar de muchas de las montañas más
altas de todo el mundo en concreto en
este país que tiene una superficie
similar a la de nicaragua podemos
encontrar 8 de las 14 cumbres con más de
8000 metros que hay en el mundo incluido
por supuesto el everest
no sólo eso en total hay 240 picos con
más de 6000 metros vamos en otras
palabras nepal es todo un paraíso para
los amantes de la montaña y por cierto
katmandú su capital la capital del
himalaya es también una de las ciudades
más queridas por los mochileros de todo
el mundo porque
pues tal vez tenga algo que ver que ésta
sea una ciudad de templos pagodas y
callejuelas llenas de vida una capital
donde en pleno siglo 21 no vais a poder
encontrar rascacielos ni avenidas anchas
ni autobuses modernos ni prácticamente
ninguna franquicia de lujo
suena bien verdad algo así como un
último resquicio de la historia en los
tiempos modernos desgraciadamente amigos
nepal también es uno de los países más
pobres del mundo según naciones unidas
nepal es uno de los países de asia que
peor puntúan el índice de desarrollo
humano bueno de asia y de prácticamente
todo el planeta porque amigos nepal se
sitúa en la posición 144 y no es para
menos
[Música]
fijaos a pesar de tener casi 30 millones
de habitantes su economía es más pequeña
que la de bolivia cuya población apenas
supera los 10 millones es decir en
términos per cápita bolivia es tres
veces más rico que nepal
[Música]
por eso cada día que pasa a unos 1500
jóvenes 1500 jóvenes se marchan al
extranjero y es que amigos los nepalíes
no lo han tenido nada pero que nada
fácil queréis saber porque pues atentos
[Música]
un país sometido
amigos el sistema político de nepal ha
estado anclado en el pasado hasta
prácticamente antes de ayer y hasta el
año 2008 este país fue una monarquía de
corte absolutista bajo el control
exclusivo del rey y por cierto como
curiosidad a pesar de ser la tierra
natal del mismísimo buda hasta el 2006
fue el único país del mundo con el
hinduismo como religión oficial
pero no sólo eso entre 1996 y 2006 el
país sufrió una guerra civil entre las
fuerzas del gobierno las fuerzas de una
monarquía dictadura y los rebeldes
maoístas partidarios de establecer una
república comunista
tal cual como lo escucháis monarquía
guerra civil maoísmo sí creo que ahora
podemos entender por qué diantres este
país es tan pobre el caos ha sido tan
grande que en los últimos 30 años la
esperanza media de vida de un gobierno
ha sido de un año
[Música]
pero amigos aquí no termina todo nepal
tiene otra característica que ha
condicionado mucho su situación política
y también económica veréis como sabéis
nepal no tiene salida al mar y además os
habéis dado cuenta de quiénes son sus
únicos vecinos exactamente nepal se
encuentra entre dos grandes colosos
entre las que seguro serán dos de las
grandes potencias de este siglo la india
y china- dos países que además no se
llevan del todo bien como ya vimos aquí
en visual político sí creo que podemos
decir que china e india son
prácticamente las únicas preocupaciones
serias que tiene el ministerio de
exteriores de este país pues bien el
caso es que tradicionalmente buena parte
gracias a que la orografía lo favorece
nepal ha sido una especie de país
satélite de la india algo que el
gobierno de nueva delhi siempre ha
tenido muy claro
la india quiere micro gestionar nepal
tienen que controlar todas las citas del
gobierno tienen que saberlo todos sus
embajadores se comportan como virreyes
pero acaso no somos una nación soberana
que son seres está director del
semanario nepalí gana hasta y miembro de
la junta directiva del consejo de prensa
de nepal tal vez la mejor prueba de como
la india ha querido siempre controlar
los destinos de este remoto país la
tuvimos en 2015
[Música]
en aquel momento amigos las fuerzas
políticas que estaban diseñando la nueva
constitución de la recién creada
república federal democrática de nepal
pues bien en nueva delhi exigió que
nepal crea si una provincia separada
para las personas de ascendencia india
que viven en las llanuras de tera y una
región en el sur de nepal en la frontera
con la india
algo a lo que las fuerzas políticas
nepalíes se opusieron con rotundidad no
establecería bajo ningún concepto
separaciones políticas en base a la
identidad pues bien como en nueva delhi
no tuvo una respuesta afirmativa os hago
una pregunta que creéis que hizo pues ni
más ni menos que bloquear las fronteras
no de forma oficial pero los camiones
con provisiones dejaron de pasar esto
sería algo malo malísimo bajo cualquier
circunstancia pero es que el bloqueo
además se produjo cuando el país peor lo
estaba pasando poco después de sufrir un
enorme terremoto que causó enormes daños
en nepal el terremoto de magnitud 7 y 8
que sacudió nepal el 25 de abril de 2015
además de cobrarse más de 8.700 vidas y
destruir medio millón de casas movió la
montaña más alta del mundo y sabéis que
este no ha sido ni el único bloqueo ni
la única estrategia que india ha
utilizado para presionar a los políticos
nepalíes a seguir sus consejos al fin y
al cabo el comercio con la india es tan
importante que tradicionalmente ha
representado casi las 3
partes de todo el comercio de nepal
pero ahora tras siglos de monarquía
absoluta y décadas de guerra y caos me
está viendo cómo las cosas comienzan a
normalizarse y como la democracia se
abre paso y sobre todo cómo se abre la
puerta de china
la llegada de china
sin en nepal comparten una frontera de
1400 kilómetros y amigos en los últimos
años esta frontera se ha puesto de moda
las relaciones comerciales entre ambos
países se han multiplicado por tres
desde el año 2010 además china se ha
convertido ya en el país que cada año
más dinero invierte en nepal y el
turismo procedente de la gran potencia
asiática crece como la espuma tan sólo
en la última década y a pesar del
terremoto el número de turistas chinos
que cada año llega a nepal se ha
multiplicado por 4 en la actualidad las
relaciones entre china y nepal se están
desarrollando al ritmo más rápido que
hemos visto nunca
joo hong embajador de china en nepal así
es como están creciendo las relaciones
entre nepal y china con la
hidroelectricidad a punto de cimentarse
los negocios chinos ya están alrededor
de este pequeño país sudasiático los
proveedores de internet chinos están
rompiendo el monopolio indio los
turistas chinos están inundando nepal
instituciones dedicadas al idioma chino
están creciendo rapidísimo más
y es están viajando a china india y
cientos de altos cargos del gobierno
nepalí son invitados a china cada año
como parte de toda una campaña de
adulación sin precedentes pero sabéis
que aún hay más
[Música]
a finales de 2017 se celebran elecciones
para elegir un nuevo parlamento y un
nuevo gobierno la victoria del partido
comunista fue aplastante un partido
comunista muy pero que muy influenciado
por pekín ahora el nuevo primer ministro
carga brasa toli se ha fijado como
prioridad número uno impulsar las
relaciones con su vecino del norte para
hacer crecer el comercio y las
inversiones pero también para ganar
independencia de la india y amigos pekín
tiene claro que no va a desaprovechar
esta oportunidad por eso ya ha puesto
sobre la mesa grandes proyectos que
pueden cambiar para siempre la situación
de nepal carreteras aeropuertos y sobre
todo la promesa de una nueva línea de
ferrocarril
[Música]
cartagena tras ver solamente
en
[Música]
el gobierno chino ha hecho público que
está estudiando extender el ferrocarril
que conecta el tíbet con la costa
oriental hasta la frontera con nepal y
por supuesto hay pocas dudas de que
china no tendría ningún problema en
financiar la construcción del
ferrocarril hasta katmandú
ojo porque no hablamos de un proyecto
precisamente pequeño conectar nepal y
china por ferrocarril podría suponer
multiplicar por 10 por 15 o incluso por
20 la llegada de turistas chinos y no
sólo eso si el tren además se conectará
con la red de ferrocarril indias
podríamos hablar de una revolución en el
tráfico de mercancías entre los dos
grandes colosos
si podemos conectar esta red ferroviaria
a nuestro proyecto ferroviario
este-oeste podemos revolucionar el
comercio china india con nepal en el
medio ya que está atrasado lee primer
ministro de nepal a ver no es que el
nuevo gobierno pretenda ni mucho menos
romper completamente con la india pero
todo apunta a que nepal ha dejado de ser
un subordinado de nueva delhi y lo más
importante por primera vez parece que
este país tiene opciones claras de
lograr un futuro mejor
queréis saber cómo atentos
el futuro agua y montañas
amigos lo hemos dicho nepal es uno de
los países más pobres de todo el planeta
pero no tiene por qué seguir siéndolo me
explico por un lado nepal es un país con
naturaleza montañas paisajes exóticos y
una gastronomía impresionante no es un
secreto que su potencial turístico es
enorme sobre todo si mejoran las
comunicaciones con china como hemos
visto es muy probable que ocurra a quien
no le gustaría visitar nepal
[Música]
pero ahí no termina todo ni mucho menos
y el gran tesoro oculto de nepal es el
agua tal cual como lo escucháis el agua
a lo mejor
pero
veréis como ya hemos visto nepal es un
país con montañas enormes y valles
escarpados que han sido dados por
grandes ríos de hechos ríos tan
importantes como el ganges nacen aquí en
el himalaya nepalí y que se puede hacer
con toda esta riqueza natural pues
los estudios que ha realizado el
gobierno nepalí muestran que los
abundantes recursos hídricos de nepal
pueden producir enormes cantidades de
energía hidroeléctrica a muy bajo coste
en concreto la capacidad potencial de
producción eléctrica podría ser de casi
el 50% la mitad de toda la producción de
los mismísimos eeuu y eso amigos es
mucha pero que mucha electricidad además
os habéis dado cuenta de otro detalle
nepal se encuentra entre india y china y
muy cerquita de bangladesh tres
economías en rápido crecimiento cuyo
consumo eléctrico se está disparando
y amigos este país nepal puede tener la
capacidad de suministrarles la
electricidad más barata de todas claro
que hasta ahora nada de esto ha sido
explotado pero todo apunta a que este
abandono puede quedar atrás muy rápido
si el país recobra la estabilidad los
inversores harán cola para financiar y
desarrollar este tipo de proyectos el
único recurso que tenemos como los
países árabes tienen con el petróleo es
el agua
xavi guide director del proyecto
hidroeléctrico de ras urbana de una
planta de 111 megavatios en construcción
cerca de la frontera con china y no sólo
eso habéis pensado que el acercamiento a
china podría lograr que el dinero chino
llegará al país para financiar grandes
proyectos hidroeléctricos pues eso es
precisamente lo que está pensando el
gobierno nepalí el nuevo primer ministro
comunista reiniciará un proyecto
liderado por chinos de 2.500 millones de
dólares que fue retirado por el anterior
gobierno gobierno que era considerado
amistoso hacia la india en fin amigos
así están las cosas
nepalés
es muy pobre pero con nuevas políticas
podría dejar de serlo ahora bien será el
nuevo gobierno capaz de dejar atrás sus
inclinaciones ideológicas y apostar por
la estabilidad la apertura y la
inversión extranjera amigos sólo el
tiempo será capaz de responder a esta
pregunta pero ahora turno para ti crees
que nepal debe apostar por china o debe
continuar estrechando lazos con la india
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta si te ha
resultado interesante el vídeo dale a
like y no olvides suscribirte a visual
polític para seguir descubriendo cosas
interesantes que pasan en nuestro mundo
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]